[Music]
in traumatising or nah I was just
completely traumatized from the sweat
you guys get submitted by hey there
Delila that song is so good people are
furious appearance who used a filter to
trick kids into seeing spiders on their
face that's fun hmm it's like at
Disneyland in the haunted house where a
ghost comes comes home with you I used
to cry at the end of that that ride you
know what the ghost is ruining my
mansion I was so I was I could not
believe they put a ghost on me I was
like furious why would a ghost on you if
you've never been in no haunted mansion
there's a ghost in the mirror but it's
your reflection so it looks like it's
with you it looks like the ghost is
sitting on you especially if you're like
in a wait no no what are you come on you
the first person has a minute Disneyland
him I've been once with my axe you don't
want to go huh I don't like it got it
yeah but the haunted house is that where
it is yeah not a mansion and it looks
like a ghost is sitting on you I lived
in a haunted mansion it felt like there
was ghosts around me all the time when I
was also married see them probably at
some point I'm gonna throw that out
there you'll see it doesn't matter you
know now you have ghosts of your past
but I can see you guys definitely
putting spiders on your kid yeah for
sure
all right here we go maybe some clips
will tell you I'll tell you off air they
don't even fit on here oh don't steal it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm so glad my dad did not have access
to that kind of technology or LC
monetize all of us so much more oh yeah
I feel like our dads are the same thing
with my fake spiders in the middle of
the night with these [ __ ] scary
gloves yeah he'd like I'm coming to get
you and you're like oh Jesus it was
funny my dad cut his hair and I freaked
out so I didn't think it was my dad
anymore did he have like long hair no he
had like probably like Bart's length or
a little bit longer hair and then he
buzzed it off like completely like Stone
Cold Steve Austin like completely bald
yeah but like a like this much it was it
were like you could see his head oh I
see and I freaked out and then he made
me pet it and I was like oh it feels
like a kitty and then I was like older
yeah I was fourth yeah but I freaked out
because I was like that's not my dad
having strong my dad used to put fake
[ __ ] everywhere to like literally like
fake [ __ ] oh he loved it won't fix it
freak poop like fake [ __ ] like literal
actual fake [ __ ] yeah translate yeah did
you what kind of [ __ ] the way a human
are fair like it would be a big dog [ __ ]
dog poop yeah did you ever believe it a
lot yeah yeah mm-hmm and I like would
freak out
you believe all of them or you like that
one looks kind of fake but these three
look kind of real we had so many animals
like coming in and out so like I never
really knew where did you live again
Georgia on a farm farm no in a really
big house but like I don't know what the
[ __ ] happened like our family like a
deer walks by she's like oh I could have
been the deer or that could have been
yeah we had just so many different
animals I'm like where did they go none
of them stayed except for like what I
don't know where all of the animals
ended up where they liked ah dogs and
cats dogs cats with my mom like so not
good at taking care of rabbits oh I know
they died the hamsters died but then
other than those deaths I don't know
where where the other ones ended up no
ran away which I think that she gave
them away to people to be honest Rollins
didn't tell me cuz she was over it she's
a single mom and she's like I'm done
with the [ __ ] like you're enough and
that's been she chopped off my hair she
did everything she could to give you
commitment issues yeah abandonment
commitment all that and I get rejected
so much that it's just like you know
what [ __ ] it all I'm actually dating
myself till the end of the year very
nice are you married myself okay yeah
yeah and this cup it's not real by the
way
what do you promote and doing it's not
really drinking the straws like okay
maybe this is your nothing thank you and
say there's something you know though
it's alcohol I'm just kidding I was
gonna say sit is nuts enough that I
believe it if you were well they you
know they get here at your old brand
[ __ ] with you just throwing it back
he's like oh say something super
offensive that I hope you cry Bel Air
it's just your brand you're nuts nuts
you seem like you're unique oh my god
pull it off thank you you said that I
almost thought you just thought I had
nuts cuz I pulled back so hard on the
chair I was like
I'm trying so hard oh you are killing
the game okay so let me guess there's a
bunch of angry people on Twitter since
we've these abusive Oh like how did you
know did you read it
yeah oh [ __ ] oh damn why you put that
baby through that trauma you had a
pocket that's my ass off keep going oh
wait your baby to end up like me don't
do that to your kid I think a little bit
was fine when they go ah and then the
kid starts freaking out and they're like
no no it's fake I'm fine yeah
what happened like why did we all laugh
when the because it's a truthful human
reaction it's juvenile and we are the
ones that know the secret when we're
children yeah I can't stop laughing at
that guy sorry that was really funny
and I shouldn't laugh at it cuz it's
that but whatever the fact that she
didn't react or getting bit in the way
she was like did I get it she wasn't
even like an owl he was like you trying
to win that approval so hot did it get
more poor baby give him here oh I'm
doing this to your kid I'll beat you up
if you do I'll pull that wig off [ __ ]
boom don't you try it or you too girl my
hands are here glide over here like no
no I'm sick oh yeah just like so this is
being widely shared especially that
first clip that was the one that started
it off because it it was tweeted out
with the caption now look at this dress
on my nephew's face and and then that
same person put in the same thread like
let's make a thread and laugh about how
dumb kids are and so they've just been
doing like replying with a whole bunch
of kids freaking out as you guys saw so
it's a pretty funny snapchat filter
what's the dumbest thing you guys think
that you did as a child I believed in
magic
I watched home alone I tried to get my
brother to step on a nail on the stairs
oh [ __ ]
you know and I was like no you got a
step right there right there you get
that step in the wrong part of the
stairs
exactly we used to play war with my
neighbor and his older brother and then
I had a side door and I tied like his
two-by-four it's to the top of a bush
and I tied like a fishing line so if he
opened the door and he would like chase
after us if you open it the two-by-four
come and smack him on the head I come
alone yeah and then so when we're
running back to our home base I'm like
oh don't don't open the door Eric don't
open the door and of course like we're
nine and he's 15 he sees a two-by-four
he just grabs his toilet I don't know as
everyone was saying their stories I'm
like what have I done
okay I'm gonna hit you afterwards and I
was like yeah it sucks when that happens
I I mean like I just didn't know what to
Farr was like where like my brother was
between the door and the wall you know
when you open the door and like it's
like between the door in the wall and I
was like leaning against him I'm like
you got to sit you got to sit or
whatever it was and he was like this
doesn't even hurt and it's not even
hurting and so then I was like going
harder and then like he kept taunting me
and then by the time I wasn't even
trying but I wasn't trying to like hurt
him but he was like doesn't hurt me and
then I went too far and it like Pierce
to the doorknob appears to see her oh I
don't know it like I like this and it
it's like I guess pierced his ear like
it just cut his ear I have a similar
story with violence to his siblings are
so violent I know and then I felt so bad
and then my parents were yelling at me
but I already felt bad because I wasn't
even trying to hurt him yeah you like it
just happened yeah my sister I danced
myself in a bar stool one time because
my sister was spinning me and then one
time she picked me up and we're doing
penitent donkey but she had my dad's
shirt on and she tripped and dropped me
on my chin and busted open my chin and I
trusted the [ __ ] okay
and then probably the third thing I had
done was really stupid was do strip
Macarena for my grandmother after I saw
striptease when I was six [ __ ] strip
Michelina okay you got two six and I was
like thank God
it wasn't the right demo it wasn't the
right demo but I did it with my sister I
thought it was Grandma and Grandpa oh
for sure yeah at least I was thinking
about that what are the rules of strip
Macarena you go like this and then every
time you did that you took off up it
used to come how far did you get
we were naked on the chair and she was
just like where did you learn that
and I was like dads we watched
striptease you know
oh you busted him and wonder why my
sister is a stripper now and I'm who I
am
foreshadowing hey you know what though
you have the stripper backstory which
one well the same same backstory is like
most strippers have thank you okay thank
you I'm gonna put that in my not a
stripper how cool is that that's well I
don't know financially you know like the
respect thing is great I guess even
though I still get like horrible
comments or whatever but the yeah I
don't think I I'm too sensitive okay
I'm way too sensitive to do that I can't
do that because I would make so much
money if I did it but I just can't they
kill it we were at a strip club recently
me and Bart shooting something and they
have a thing on the wall that shows how
much strippers can make in a year and
it's [ __ ] nuts shut up I'm not gonna
how many times they go up at night it's
crazy
they're like trying to recruit new
strippers yeah it's like a pain it's
like a pay chart if you go up once there
are some numbers I took a picture of it
I'll show you yes they're basically
saying like want to be a millionaire and
it's like here's how many dances you
have to do a week and a nine [ __ ] and
like it actually tracks yeah
gosh you're making me feel really really
bad about just dancing for free on
Instagram are you should strip
[Music]
[Music]